adult men come in by themselves sit on
my lap take a picture and I'd look at
him I say this is for Mom right yep I've
done it every year since I was five
years old and I'm gonna keep doing it
until I die
[Music]
well hello Sandra Gerwin here from the
Fraternal Order of real bearded Santa's
and the fine folks at BuzzFeed have
asked me to share a couple of stories
with you guys from the throne and one
thing that left out at me immediately
was the suit is the biggest investment
that most Santa's have to make these
boots cost one hundred and twenty nine
dollars that was ten years ago they're
charging 850 dollars now the belt is
$400 the jacket over the chair is $900
my entire outfit cost more than 2,000 so
the biggest investment most Santa's have
is their outfit I worked for two years
in a really cheap pajama suit because it
wasn't really working I was just
donating my time doing caroling
neighborhoods things like that but when
I decided to do it for real
I had my mother-in-law make a suit for
me and she's a professional seamstress
she did a pretty good job I worked in
that suit for the next five years and
made enough money to go up to Hollywood
I made the mecca to Adele's and bellied
up to the bar and said give me your
finest and waited my eight weeks and
went back up there and picked it up and
put it on for my first big gig it's a
retirement gig for something by the
cliffs so weirdly where the millionaires
put their old people to retire and I was
in there for three hours worked every
room in the place having a really good
time the last room they took me into
there was a big cocktail party going on
I had my assistant with me that night
she was standing right behind me we were
making our way through the crowd and I
was you know just high-fiving and
glad-handing everybody and I turned
around I heard someone say Santa
I turned around and this woman had just
refilled her glass of red wine and she
came in for a hug and I could tell
immediately that it wasn't her first
glass either a whole glass of red wine
went right down my suit and I was crazy
immediately my assistant and I went to
the bathroom and we spent the next half
hour trying to make sure that that red
wine that was probably one of the
harshest nights I've had in a long time
hi my name is Tom Giddings I'm a real
bearded Santa president of the Inland
Empire Fraternal Order of real bearded
Santa's I'm here to tell you some
stories about my experience as a mall
Santa I've had children come in stand in
line for hour hour and a half I said oh
hi Santa from all all in the line all
excited to come see me and everything
they'll get up to the front of the line
of high school now look at my dress
everything and as soon as it's their
turn they'll get all excited they'll
come running they'll run over they'll
run over and as soon as they get right
at my feet
look at that horrified look in their
face they just stop they get that scream
and they're gone and they turn around
and they run right back to mom and dad
and it's all over at that point they
don't want anything to do with me
everybody tries to get him sit on my lap
nothing candy cookies nothing works for
him they just think oh my gosh he's
finally came to life and I don't know
what to do with myself now long before I
became a Santa and my wife and I we own
the production company Rick and Vic
productions and I decided that I was
going to be the singing Santa and that's
my website that's my persona my wife and
I are known as singing Santa and diva
Claus that's just one g and singing
Santa by the way so we write and produce
an original song and we perform it for
our clients exclusively and then every
year we reveal it at our annual reunion
in 2013 I was speaking at it
Rotary Club and I had a little accident
and I actually ruptured my feelings on
my left foot and like an idiot I tried
to walk it off for the next couple of
days and wound up completely tearing the
the Achilles so when I finally went to
the doctor they said you're gonna need
surgery we got to do it right away
you're gonna be in a cast we're
scheduling the surgery for November 6
you're gonna be in a cast for six weeks
do the math Santa began his Christmas
season that year in a cast on his left
leg and he got one of the orthopedic
surgeons to get one of the guys in there
to make a candy cane out of it and for a
minute we thought that my season might
be over so I started calling some of my
clients and we told him about it and
immediately they were like we don't care
if you have to bring him in here on a
gurney we want scene in Santa so we
talked about it a little bit and decided
it might be a saint a teaching moment so
I decided that since my clients expected
a new song that year anyway and since I
had a perfect opportunity to reveal this
to the kids as Santa can get an ally to
decided to the song that year my 2013
singing Santa song was Santa got run
over by a reindeer my clients now expect
me to come up with a new song every year
and although they're almost always
parody so don't have to write the music
as well they're still so well received
and I love it very much I had a child I
do I was doing a photo shoot a couple
days ago had a child on my lap screaming
hollering with mom is trying to give him
candy and cookies and every time she
would offer him something and in the
middle of a screaming cry no thank you
and then right back to screaming and
crying dad said tell Santa hohoho hohoho
and I went poof oh boo and his eyes got
about that big around he looked up at me
stop crying at that point and from then
on out we were best friends talking and
play and cook
using milk we just had a great time well
hopefully you've enjoyed all my stories
I wish I had more to tell you and more
time to tell them to you I hope you all
have a great great Christmas I have a
great Christmas every year almost every
day of the year because looking like
Santa you put joy and people's faces
every day keep Santa in your heart no
matter how old you are thank you and
have a Merry Christmas
[Music]
you
[Music]